[Music]
this guy is
I'm asking the Bob guy like he was here
you asked him questions about like to
put on being created uncreated uh
what does that mean for in terms of like
in terms of how he like single out
singling out the lordship of God I mean
like what's your honest take on that
like what do you like what are you
honest but I know what you're trying to
propose because it would be problematic
right because we we claim that there
can't be a three in one but then you
look to Islam and you say okay there's
possibly a two in one this is what it
seems like what the scholars are saying
wait what's your honest take on that
though yeah my my I I think that um
tawheed when when under scrutiny uh
falls apart bro I don't think that it's
it's consistent or at least it's not
consistent with the accusations that
Muslims throw against us as Christians
when we talk about the word of God being
Eternal and distinct from the father yet
um not separate in his essence or nature
and in Eternal and things of this nature
and uncreated which is Jesus you know we
we have this belief and stuff like that
and it seems that also
and within Islam when it comes to tahi
they have a similar belief that Allah's
word is eternal it's uncreated and it's
also distinct from him but they would
say that it's not Allah it's it's not
him so
for for that that will be two separate
uncreated entities
uh yeah that's problematic
can you yeah yeah I hear what you're
saying uh yeah okay good let bro give
his introduction if he wants to yeah
well just thank you for letting me know
I'll just I'm gonna be quick I just had
a bunch of like some questions from what
I heard uh yeah you guys knew what
you're saying are you Muslim are you
Muslim too are you Christian like what
are you alhamdulillah muslim okay yeah
no but check it out
2v2
good thing bro comparative religion is
mad fun like especially if you care
about that type of stuff but now check
it out every though there's there's four
stages there's four uh stages of taohi I
think you mentioned one of them which is
like uh like uh like yeah yeah uh well
that's like attributes but like of tauhi
like the Oneness of God and the first
one is tingling out the lordship of
Allah so like you know what Bob is
saying that there's no Partners to God
Etc now in terms of the Quran being
uncreated uh when you say uncreated that
obviously entails uh eternity yeah yeah
but everything wouldn't you agree that
everything existed eternally in the
knowledge of God it's not like God
Ponders upon you wouldn't say that God
Ponders upon new ideas like new ideas
coming to God said is God not
all-knowing this is this is knowledge
not Encompass everything yeah yeah but
yeah but that doesn't mean that uh
what's in his knowledge is is in
actuality those those questions are just
potential yeah
just yet of course yeah that's what I'm
saying so everything that that's it's
not like the Quran existed alongside
Allah eternally nothing exists you
wouldn't know you know in Islamic
theology the first thing we say was
created was the pen it's the first thing
that was created so nothing existed
eternally alongside Allah now in terms
of the Quran being uncreated it's
because it's the word of God but you do
know that on the day of judgment we
fully affirm that one of the major signs
of the day of judgment is the Quran
disappearing on every single there we
know there will be no Quran left and
Allah will destroy everything and the
only thing that will remain is the face
of Allah or the the Allah himself you
know I only say the face of Allah that's
how he described in you know he says
like what's one of the uh your Lord's
favorites and then he says that
everything will perish except for the
noble face of your lord so it's not like
you know eternity means that it has no
beginning and no end and if the the
beginning is then Allah's knowledge okay
fine but everything will be destroyed
and it will return back to and stay
eternally and Allah's knowledge but
nothing exists alongside Allah eternally
that's what you're asking
essential
well let's let's see so you have you
have something that I got what you said
I got what you said basically that you
know that's the Quran will pass away one
day it'll pass away so it's not
infinite I guess right it's not infinite
yeah nothing is infinite except except
for Allah yeah okay so you have the
Quran that's uncreated what you're
saying is it's it's uncreated in the
sense that it's in his thoughts is that
what you're saying well again we say who
could find out there's nothing
comparable to Allah so you and I have
thoughts now where uh where Allah's
knowledge is it's not like what is it in
his head I mean it wouldn't be like uh
uh comprehensible I mean I'm not sure
we could say sin is knowledge of course
but does it actually exist hello hello
so when it's in his thoughts does it
actually exist though well of course not
there's nothing you turn alongside Allah
but it's in his knowledge all right so
what the scholars are teaching is that
the Quran actually existed
yeah but you know there's I mean I'm
pretty sure you would know that there's
a debate among Scholars uh and there's
different there's differences of opinion
of course and it's not wrong for any
Muslim to take like a minority a pendant
this isn't problematic at all okay so as
long as we're understanding that
according to the majority of Islam
that the Quran is uncreated and has
always existed along along with Allah
a majority opinion they're saying the
Quran is uncreated is that something
that we just that we subscribe to yes
the word of Allah of course it's
uncreated but that means that it exists
along with Allah in the knowledge of
Allah
all right so first things
because we have to make sure that we
establish terms so we don't talk past
each other and like go in service so me
and you agreed that if just because
something is in Allah's knowledge does
not mean it exists yet it's just
potential right okay so it's something
that's in Allah's knowledge that will
eventually be created in actuality okay
okay the Quran itself though is
uncreated
it's uncreated meaning that it's it
exists in actuality and has been
existing in actuality it has not been
existing in actuality before it was
revealed and even even if you want to
say it's on the Heavenly tablet that's
also creation remember I mean if you
want to talk about Islam I'm not talking
about that either yeah of course I'm
saying if I'm saying if you were to take
that road like of course you would go to
the Heavenly tub is like the the normal
thing that I don't know some Christians
that I speak to they go there next well
bro I mean you can't I mean if you're
gonna not I'm not gonna say a tech but
if you're gonna question this part of
the theology you would have to affirm
and you can't disregard the other one as
well which is the first thing that was
created what's the PIN now you're saying
that yeah but yeah the first thing was
brought into existence now bro is it not
that Allah says in the Quran that he
creates uh with the word as well he says
you're going too fast let's let's take
this very slow
the first thing the first thing that was
brought into existence was the pin yeah
but according according to the Islamic
scholars and his teaching on this about
the Quran the Quran was never brought
into existence it wasn't created
the pin was though okay yeah that's
exactly yeah
so that would mean that the Quran was
there before the pen was because the
Quran is not created while the pen was
brought into existence the Quran was
never brought into existence it always
existed and and where because when
you're saying it always existed where
like like Allah existed and then the
Quran was next to him is it not that
everything existed and not okay let me I
just want to bring on to the second
point before you said that let's go
slower but is it not that Allah also
creates by saying like
yeah so he says be and it is so does he
also not create those things by the word
like our souls did he not tell it to be
and it is
so is it not the the for example say our
souls are created by the word
sure you can say that okay but does that
mean that that our souls uh since
they're created by the word of God that
they're also uncreated as well
I think you're missing it the the word
the word of Allah being the source of
the existence of another thing
oh yeah so yeah yeah the separation
between like Allah's word between like
what Allah's word creates
correct okay well I think yeah because
what you're what you're bringing towards
is uh something being boundless like
Allah's boundless you say he has no
beginning and no end now if you if we
say that the Quran has no beginning
because it's uncreated where it would
exists would be inside the knowledge of
Allah and now you're saying that okay
now something uncreated does exist with
us but I'm saying that even if that has
an end so that would break the whole
claim of it being Eternal has an end
well so so I didn't say Eternal but I
said uncreated so if something is and
and if it has an end then there's
another another issue there too then but
just going slow if G if um the war if
the Quran is uncreated and existed with
Allah okay that means that there are
because it cannot that would mean that
dude that means it literally existed
outside of his mind it's in it's in
actuality it's not just in his mind of
course it's in his knowledge nothing but
what I'm saying is is that it's not it's
in actuality of course he knows all
things but there's an actual thing that
exists the Quran it actually exists
and what like like and words or what do
you say on the on the tablet or whatever
whatever
nature it was the Quran whatever the
Quran is it existed with Allah it was
uncreated it existed this thing from
Allah
yeah but yeah before you before you said
let me respond before Allah says being
that is does that also exist with Allah
and that's what he says yeah
like let's say before Allah creates
something says being it is does that
exist within with with Allah are you
saying the something or the word yeah so
is the word is Allah's speech separate
from himself
that's that's the question for you is it
no but but I'm asking because you're
saying the the Quran existed outside of
Allah like outside of Allah
it doesn't exist inside of his knowledge
no so like for example because you would
say you I don't think you follow Divine
Simplicity do you as a mother what is
yeah
would you say that uh Allah's knowledge
is his power or are those two distinct
attributes yeah so this is what I was
talking about the Lady Mary Mary Harvey
yesterday about uh distinct attributes
within Allah and we spoke about how it's
only problematic for a human being to
comprehend why because our deciphering
tool is language so when we speak about
Allah's attributes whether they're
distinct or not we say one which is the
other and in terms of how they're
perfectly fused together within Allah
being a perfect being I mean bro there
will be no proper way to conceptualize
it I mean bro I thought so do you do you
affirm that there are different
attributes
that Allah's Mercy is distinct from his
anger yeah okay yeah but are they all
attributed to one person
sure sure so so so so so it's these
different attributes that make up
that combine to make up Allah right they
don't make they don't make up Allah
for example like let's say let's say uh
because they're completely indivisible
and the same way the the base of of my
hand is an atom is the atom itself
indivisible okay wait wait wait
let's keep it to Allah's attributes no
we are we are but I have to bring this
analogy because yeah I'm sorry to cut
you up I'm not better
it's okay this is a good conversation
the speech of Allah okay his speech is
his speech him is it is it equal to him
no of course A distinct from him of
course not it's the word of God of God
right so his speech is distinct from him
right okay yet it is
still a part of his Essence right
of his Essence yeah because it proceeds
from Allah his speech proceeds from him
so it's part of his Essence even though
it's distinct from him bro uh can I ask
yeah of course I'll answer your question
but can I ask you a question bro
you know that the Muslims affirmallah
so it's not that the Quran isn't the
word of God or we don't affirm that but
it's not worthy of worship you're never
going to find a Muslim bowing down to
the Quran yeah so there's a there's a a
distinction obviously between it's not
like we're going to worship Allah saying
be and it is Allah we're all going to
worship and now we're going to worship
Allah his word is not his word is not
worthy of worship he himself is worthy
of worship
no problem so so here's my thing my
thing here with taheed is being about
the uniqueness of Allah and his
attributes like the specifically the
tahit I'm talking about unique the
uniqueness of Allah the unification of
his attributes he's the only one with
these with these attributes it cannot be
applied to anything else in creation
okay okay yeah
right one of these things one of these
attributes is is him being uncreated you
know self-sufficient he he didn't come
into existence that's one of these
attributes of Allah okay so this cannot
be applied to anything else other than
Allah or until he breaks
okay my problem is yeah so my so my
problem is is that
this attribute of uncreatedness is being
applied to something that is not Allah
okay that's fine I'll answer your
question yeah I'll answer your question
uncreatedness entails what
Intel is always existing exactly always
found this no no end no beginning so if
in the beginning
if in the beginning Allah existed and
everything exists within his knowledge
okay fine okay then the Quran is here
okay Quran on Earth the speech uh
uncreated fun but the Quran itself will
come to an end
it won't exist anymore everything
increasing even the angels that hold
Allah's Throne will come to perish
everything so it's not Eternal alongside
Allah bro I see the point that you're
that you're I see what you're proposing
and I see how it'd be uh how it would be
beneficial to to the biblical narrative
and what you're saying is not it's not
like you're just bringing out some
hogwash this is a what you're what
you're speaking on is a is a scholarly
uh uh debate like among Scholars so what
we're just speaking on it has some some
elements of Truth in it but nothing is
like Allah there's nothing comparable to
him he's completely unique so nothing
will be Eternal alongside Allah so it
wrote It's not like for example like you
like you believe on the day of judgment
that Jesus Christ will still exist
because of course they're all one being
they're one being I'm not saying that
you believe in three different gods I
understand the Trinity but you're saying
that Jesus Christ will exist forever as
will the father and as with the Holy
Spirit again because they're one being
not because they're three different gods
but the three different persons
representing one being but these three
persons will always exist yeah their
eternity on the day of judgment they
also exist yeah that's not the same in
Islam it's not the same
conceptualization Quran will come to an
end the angels I hold Allah Stone will
come to an everything increasing will
come to it and accept Allah and then
Allah will say might is for Allah power
is for Allah and then he'll bring
everything back into existence so bro I
mean I hope that clears up the the
the miss the not misconception like I
say it's a misconception it's not just
something you're thinking about but I
hope that clears it that nothing is
eternal alongside him so the only thing
that you're saying is that the only
difference between Allah and the Quran
here is that the Quran will one day come
to an end
so this is where this is where our
problem is this is where the problem is
is that you have the speech of Allah
which is the Quran right yeah this is an
attribute of Allah
and you're saying that it will come to
an end an attribute of Allah will come
to an end that's a problem
an attribute of Allah will come to an
end yes because the Quran okay if the
Quran was uh gone from his from his
knowledge this would be problematic did
it exist okay in the beginning let's
okay let's look in the beginning it
existed where infinitely in his
knowledge okay then he bestows him no no
no no no not infinitely in it support my
goodness right so uh harun you believe
that Allah from the beginning from
eternity's past has known everything of
course including us including you right
of course
are you uncreated
no of course I'm created exactly so you
were CR even though you existed in
Allah's knowledge always like you not
even existed just that Allah knew about
you always does not equate to existence
okay so the Quran when it says that the
Quran is uncreated that means that it
actually had existence
it existed
okay yeah uncreated not just in thought
okay okay this this YSU before Allah
speaks
does his speech exist
that's a according to the doctrine yes
according to the doctrine this speech is
eternal okay so before he before he
speaks where does his where does his
speech exist that's a great question for
you not me in the knowledge of Allah
no but if so if the Quran if the Quran
isn't uncle but you're also saying the
Quran is is eternal so that's the
problem that you're having like okay
those two oh yeah yeah you're saying
it's not yeah so those two statements
don't go hand in hand that's that's
where you're having a problem at I mean
it's it's not problematic we look at it
sequentially like in that timeline
straight are you saying that the speech
of Allah will come to an end
on Earth not in the knowledge of Allah
bro I said what did I say earlier did I
not say that it would be a problem it
would be a problem if the if the it was
revealed to humanity and then it uh it
disappears from Earth or something like
that ends on the earth and then it also
ends in the knowledge of Allah okay then
something's missing we have knowledge
being taken away from Allah but it will
exist infinitely in the knowledge of
Allah as this that's not existence
it's not existing because look just as
you just admitted you came into
existence right
there was a point in time where you
harun came into existence okay yes right
but but at the same time you would also
say that Allah infinitely knew about you
you were always you were infinitely in
Allah's knowledge okay right but that
doesn't mean that you have infinitely
existed correct
not not in not in actualization not in
like in form no thank you so that's what
existence is existence is actuality it's
not potential something that's potential
doesn't exist yet
it has something then that's potential
will or has the potential to exist okay
so you're speaking on if God makes a
decision is it necessary or not
that's not what I'm speaking now what
yeah yeah this is exactly what you're
speaking on the Quran is uncreated so
you're saying that it's uh uh couldn't
have been any other way so the way that
it exists inside uh inside of the way
exists it has always existed correct yes
it always existed yes yes and the way
that it's just like as if Allah didn't
have a decision uh whether to reveal it
and the way he revealed it or not
well so there couldn't have been no
changes to it because it's always been
the same it couldn't have been he could
not have been no changes yeah no that's
another problem Allah said what does it
does Allah not say
I'm saying does Allah not say that uh
how do you wield it he could have uh he
could destroy Humanity he could have
destroyed Humanity entirely and Place
Angels on the earth as successors and
there will be like no need for the Quran
the Quran would have never been needed
so I'm saying so so I'm saying so for
things that exist they're not necessary
if if Allah doesn't will to reveal it
time out
so those things are not contradictory
Allah having if he wanted to could just
destroy creation get rid of humanity
then there being no need for the Quran
to be revealed doesn't negate the fact
that the Quran exists yeah
I should have clarified yeah like we
said if Allah like before Allah says
because uh earlier we talked about like
the souls and how of Allah says be and
it is and the soul is created this is
why I was alluding towards that the
souls were created by Allah's word okay
now does the decision that Allah makes
is it absolutely necessary like can he
can he change his decisions and that's
why I brought the verse in southern
Quran to say that if Allah will he could
have destroyed Humanity in the same
sense that if Allah didn't want to
reveal the Quran he didn't have to
reveal the Quran and the same way that
the way that the Quran was revealed
Allah could have made uh different words
differently
or or take out certain words and put it
back which is why we affirm abrogation
that Allah says inside the Quran that if
uh when how whenever he calls uh causes
a verse from the Quran to be forgotten
uh he replaces it with the verse that's
better so you affirm abrogation so think
certain things were revealed to the
prophet Muhammad for some that weren't
meant for the rest of humanity we also
affirm the seven you know the seven
letters in which the way that the Quran
was revealed seven minutes of recitation
so do wait do you do I don't think you
realize the problems you're raising up
right now I'm saying if the Quran is
uncreated
this is this is a great point if the
Quran is uncreated how can a verse be
deleted or gone because if it's
uncreated because it's it's uncreated
when Allah determines the way that it's
going to be so it's it's you make it but
you're making it seem as if Allah had to
reveal the Quran in the way that he had
to like he's like the like the decisions
that he decides to make is absolutely
necessary bro this is not the case bro
but I feel like you already know this
wait wait wait so like
you're saying that so you're saying the
Quran let me just ask this real quick
real quick you're saying the Quran is
you're saying the Quran is
pre-abrogated and uncreated at the same
time okay let's make this clear okay
no now we're speaking on because bro
you're we're both theists so we both uh
agree on the existence of God and this
is a a point where atheists come and try
to attack uh theists or people who
believe in God this is the point uh is
is God's decisions that he makes uh
determined or undetermined like his own
decisions I mean and this would be a
problem not even a problem this would be
like a a fun thing to entertain for all
theists I mean because it goes for
everything it's like you guys believe
that each person inside the Trinity has
not their own will but it's all one will
they all have the same exact will so is
the things that they will is it uh
absolutely necessary or can they make it
a different decision as well and bro
obviously if we offer an abrogation then
what uh whatever Allah Wills to be uh uh
in the Quran for the rest of humanity to
read then it's there whatever he does
and doesn't so he's the determiner uh of
his decisions it's not like something
else is determining his decisions
okay so you have a uncreated Quran a
Quran that actually exists
that is there all of its verses all of
its ayats yeah right there in in the
Quran uncreated
right
like you said it becomes uncreated when
Allah determines what it's going to be
how in the same way how can something
become if it's uncreated that's what I'm
saying so in the same way Allah says be
and it is he's and before he says it
where does it exist and his knowledge
now could he have made a different
decision could he could he have created
myself
you keep going back to this which is I'm
I'm you're not being consistent I'm
trying to show you where you're
inconsistent dude okay if you're you're
saying that something in Allah's
knowledge
exists
that's that's what you just said but at
the same time agreed with me that you
didn't always exist even though you were
in Allah's knowledge
okay so yeah again we need to stay on
one we need to make sure that we are on
one thing so we don't keep going in a
circle that's fine so we can move
forward yeah yeah of course hunt it I
brought the the I paraphrased what we're
speaking on and is is it is God's uh
decisions that he makes is it determined
or is it undetermined and I already said
that we affirm abrogation so bro the
Quran
and the uh and the way that it was
revealed to the prophet Muhammad some
verses were revealed and then some
verses were caused to be forgotten and
then some verses were uh replaced with
something that's better or something
that's uh perfect for Humanity to read
after him so bro the whole stance gets
broken when you affirm abrogation you're
saying that the way that the Quran
you're saying that the way that the
Quran is now uh uh is the uh and the
knowledge of Allah but the when the
Quran is being revealed some verses were
caused to be forgotten and some verses
were abrogated this clear clearly stated
in the Quran and there's evidences in
the Quran as well this whole thing is is
this this whole this whole notion of the
Quran being uncreated okay we already
established that it will come to an end
and then you said it's problematic that
it's going to come to an end because
it's uncreated because the way that it
exists now it has always existed in the
knowledge of Allah and then I told you
that Allah is the determiner of his own
decisions so he could choose what stays
inside the Quran what doesn't because
we're from abrogation there's some
verses
slow down so when you you clarified what
you meant by it's it's going to
disappear not from existence but from
this Earth okay just like the Quran
existed before coming on this Earth
before he brought it down and revealed
it to the Earth
you're saying that he's going to take it
away from the earth not so that doesn't
mean that it's going to cease to exist
that only that is not going to be here
present on the earth anymore
okay
so what are you trying to say
so you're saying that the Quran will
come to an end okay
existentially but that's not the case if
all you're saying is that oh yeah Allah
is just going to remove it from the
earth not that it's not going to exist
anymore of course it's going to continue
to exist in the knowledge of God okay so
when something is equal everything else
bro got it I'm gonna ask you this one
thing and I want you to be clear with me
inshallah okay be clear with me
like again I'm not a speller just a
thinker just like you are oh yes it's
simple trust me it's very simple okay
good did you exist in the in the
knowledge of God before you were created
uh yeah
did you always exist
no
thank you so being in the knowledge of
God does not equal existence correct
no existence in the way that exists no
no
okay so being in the knowledge of God
does not equal existence okay
potentiality not actuality okay good so
now that we have that settled let's stop
going to the knowledge of God and
referring to it as existence because
that's not existence
no no okay okay
existence physically in this world and
this universe for me no existence for me
existing from my Human Experience
obviously is not the same as existing
before I existed in the knowledge of God
yeah but bro is is God sexuality yeah of
course but actuality is not something
that uh God is limited but you agree and
please answer this you agree that God is
all seeing and all-knowing and all
hearing so is it not that God
understands not only what's uh decreed
but also what the possibilities are
potentialities infinitely of what
anything else could have been
and it is all seeing and all-knowing and
all hearing of those uh uh possible
instances as well yes do those possible
instances exist already
and the knowledge of God
and I hope this is something that you
affirm as a theist as well as if you
believe in an all-knowing God this is
something that you have to affirm that's
what I'm speaking with me
if you can't be consistent we're not no
no we're not don't don't go back to what
you said before addressing the new point
then stop smashing no I'm not switching
what did I say the whole time what I've
been saying God is always we literally
just gotta we literally just got on a
page for her room together no we didn't
get on the page God's knowledge does not
equal existence okay and what did I
respond to that because I don't think
you remember I agreed with that no no
what did I respond to that I said okay
okay what did I say after that because I
just explained it now we're going to go
back uh about uh 45 seconds earlier I
said from my Human Experience me
existing as a human here is not the same
as me existing and the knowledge of God
but I said to God
okay and please please follow me here
it's a God God is what all knowing
all sink
all hearing so he hears and sees and
knows all potentialities okay now what
he wants to determine uh to be in the
actual existence is up to him but
he knows and sees and hears everything
that's decreed and the same way that he
knows and hears and sees everything
that's not decreed there's no distinct
differences between the two because his
knowledge and his sight and his hearing
is absolute before you before Allah
created you in actuality were you
uncreated were you an uncreated being or
entity
okay yeah you're asking me a question uh
first I'd like to see do you agree with
what I'm saying first before we go on
another Circle you agree with what I
just proposed I understand what you're
saying but what you got it what you
gotta understand is is that you guys are
kind of talking past each other we're
not we know we're not yeah you are God
logic is is speaking of something
completely different in your
continuously trying to get us to
understand the knowledge of Allah no you
have to understand that the knowledge of
your existence does not mean the same
thing as what God logic is bringing up
he's not talking about the knowledge
because he already told you that the
knowledge that you would at some point
in time exist doesn't mean that you
pre-existed right it doesn't mean that
and you're trying to get us to
understand that yeah Allah knew that I
would exist at one point in this this
and that but that's not the conversation
that he's trying to actually have with
you so you got to kind of listen to what
God logic is saying we already
understand that if he's all-knowing of
course he knew that you would uh you
know potentially exist at one point but
that doesn't mean that you pre-existed
you understand what I'm saying yeah of
course I understand so so you gotta stop
explaining that to us because we get
that already no no okay me and God logic
uh or Avery we're establishing a
foundation of understanding because the
differences and our standpoints is
coming from our differences and
foundations of understanding now he
seems to think that Allah is limited uh
and knowledge and in seeing and in
hearing to what is going to be decreed
as if Allah is not the determiner of
what is decreed and also has knowledge
of all potentialities and understands it
and hears it and sees it in the same way
of the things that are decreed so once
we establish this is this Foundation
then this whole notion of the Quran uh
existing uh being uncreated inside the
knowledge of God and like it's
absolutely determined to exist the way
it does not as if Allah didn't
understand every single other
potentiality of the Quran uh of what it
could have been once we established that
that God's knowledge
uh encompasses fully potentialities and
he hears it and sees it and knows it the
same way that he understands and hears
and sees the things that are decreed I
mean then the whole this whole notion
will be Soul what does this knowledge
have to do with something actually
existing
because what I'm saying is it does not
matter if it actually exists or not
okay so if something when you're saying
that that shows that you not even
dealing with what I'm asking you or of
course yeah next topic
no but bro your stance or Avery your
stance will never change on anything
until you accept that God fully
encompasses and knowledge and sight and
hearing potentialities just as well and
there is no the difference I don't but I
don't have to believe that it's
consistent in Islam I can believe that
God it is knowledge encompasses all
knowledge and potentialities is that
consistent Islam in Islam I'm arguing no
what's how am I arguing no that you have
a Quran that's uncreated while at the
same time is being able to be changed
versus deleted and replaced with verses
that are better or more perfect than the
previous one that is literally
inconsistent okay and that makes no
sense so if you have here if you have
here hold on a second please because I
listened to you for a long time yeah of
course
what I'm saying but it's all good okay
good you're not dealing with what I'm
saying okay if you have something that
is uncreated
you admitted earlier you said it out of
your mouth okay that I was in the
thoughts of Allah but that doesn't mean
that I existed
so we agreed that the knowledge of Allah
and something that in in existence are
two different things they're not the
same they're two different things so
take out knowledge deal with existence
something actually existing the your
Scholars teach that the Quran is
uncreated meaning that is always existed
and there's never a time where the Quran
came into existence there's never a time
when the Quran was created it's
uncreated so if it's uncreated then
that's two things that you have that
have this attribute of uncreatedness
something that has always been because
the Quran is not Allah and Allah is
uncreated the Quran is uncreated that's
two things that you got that's uncreated
okay not in the thoughts of Allah but in
actuality
okay
that's what I want you to deal with stop
dealing with the thoughts no fine fine
okay then the knowledge of Allah is an
attribute like you said yeah
yeah okay is the knowledge of Allah
created
is it that's according to you let you
let me know this is your doctor yo well
of course bro but this is the same way
that if I'm speaking to an atheist and
giving them some philosophical argument
for the existence of God and they just
tell me okay no you tell me what you
think their stance will never change so
you have to run down the thought path as
well do you believe that Allah's
knowledge is I don't have a belief about
Allah I'm only going about what is
taught in according to your Doctrine
okay
according to your Doctrine are Eternal
or uncreated okay so okay so why would
you have a problem with with Islamic
theology if it's not even something that
you subscribe to I mean if we're going
to entertain a conversation about it if
you're going to entertain a conversation
about it so you can take a new stance uh
but then you'll opt out when I ask you a
question saying that I don't believe in
it anyway then we're not going to move
forward I'm going to ask you a question
my belief about Allah is I don't believe
I don't believe that the Allah of Islam
is real of course you know that's why
saying but I'm going with I'm going with
what your Scholars teach yeah according
to your Scholars so asking me do you
believe that Allah's knowledge is
eternal that no what does that got to do
with me no you don't answer that
question and I'll go with your answer
bro from your Christian perspective of
Islamic Theology of course sets to
That's The Stance Point you're you're
speaking Christian with respect of
Islamic theology yeah that's yeah you're
speaking from your Christian perspective
of Islamic theology I'm saying No this
is this is the Islamic perspective bro
we no no no bro bro bro bro listen I
said of course you don't believe in
Allah of course you don't you know
you're not a Muslim yeah
no no no no no no neither of us wait
wait wait bro neither of us are speaking
from our Christian Perspective this is
from Islamic theology that we're
speaking from this is the problems that
you guys have created not you more say
but in general your Scholars and things
that have argued this position it is not
coming from a Christian perspective bro
of course not of course Okay so
no what I said to Avery I said uh uh I
asked them what do you believe Allah's
knowledge is uh uncreated and then he
said I don't believe in Allah bro of
course not I'm not saying that you
believe in Allah I'm just saying like
obviously from your Christian's
perspective you're looking at it from
Islamic theology I'm not saying that you
subscribed to uh Islamic beliefs I'm
just asking from from your from your
perspective of Islamic theology do you
believe that uh Allah's knowledge is is
uncreated like what would you say to
that of course I would say according
according to Islamic theology his
knowledge is uncreated okay perfect so
Allah's knowledge is uncreated and does
he does his knowledge Encompass
absolutely everything that's
potentiality
does his knowledge possess like does he
know all things yes he knows all things
okay so all things and the knowledge of
God are uncreated now in terms of what
is is put into creation why did you just
why
oh my God him knowing something doesn't
mean that something is uh we already
we're backtracking again man yeah again
like this we're not crazy I don't know
why you keep going to the knowledge of
God and not dealing with actual
existence because you're not
understanding that the difference
between that for God means nilch nothing
I told you that the way that God
bro okay listen we already established
the knowledge would exists doesn't mean
that it exists yes okay and so you gotta
stop bringing that up you literally just
tried to slip that in no I didn't
thought we didn't catch it you did you
just said it okay I think this I think
this is a a
um a problem of of comprehension uh okay
can you restate what you just said about
it because yes okay please say it's slow
because I I don't I don't think you
understand what you're saying okay you
literally just said it
if there's something that you disagree
with then please tell me why you
disagree uh uh not that I've said this
already because obviously we're not
moving forward if we like I said earlier
like five minutes ago if we don't
establish and we don't have the same
Foundation of understanding okay now
listen
we established just know that God's
knowledge is uncreated
okay okay and we also established that
God's knowledge encompasses what's
decreed and what's potentialities as
well all of it and he's all seeing it
all hearing and all knowing of all of it
right okay now when he decides to
determine it into actual into actual
existence listen Okay when he decides to
determine it into actual existence the
actual existence and the potentialities
that exist in his knowledge have zero
difference
because he's all seeing and all hearing
of all potentialities and all things
that are actualized what Avery's purpose
so did you so wait wait hold on you
missed one thing you left one thing out
that you said you said that would make
all of that uncreated in his knowledge
when he does so are you changing your
position on that no no when he
determines it it's created but the
potentiality doesn't make it uncreated
when
okay listen when he determines it it is
okay
it is what
created it when he determines it okay
you said but you said his knowledge of
what
can I ask you a question okay I don't
think I don't think you're getting what
you're saying here I'm trying to ask you
a question so you can understand because
if I'm saying something that's that you
don't I understand what you guys are
saying I'm replying to it I don't
understand my response I'm saying when
God determines something where does it
come from what knowledge
undetermined knowledge undetermined
knowledge everything that God determines
comes from something undetermined
because that's his knowledge so the way
that God understands what's decreed and
what's not decreed he understands all of
it he's all searing all seeing all
hearing and all knowing of what's
decreed and what's not decreed
what's the difference between things
decreed and not decreed it would the
only difference would be from our human
perspective like for example my human
perspective there's potentialities of uh
I could have did something else or
something not okay I don't experience
these these different things because
they're not in front of me I can't see I
can't hear I don't know it but God knows
all of it
his knowledge is infinite infinite what
is the difference between something
determined and something not determined
that something is created and something
is untreated so if it's in the knowledge
of God it's uncreated and it is what is
this so something is in the knowledge
there we are again so we're going to
move on man we're gonna move on from
this because you're not bro I think
you're about to change your stance if
you entertain this for about a few more
minutes we finally built the foundation
no I think I think the topic is pretty
much done yeah yeah bro wow bro wow
Avery we got we got us Haroon we gotta
switch we got to switch topics you can
and you can lead the next topic because
no again honestly we've been on this way
too long and you're literally going in
circles repeating the same thing after
saying something else later okay
um but going right back to it exists in
the knowledge of God it's uncreated
let me respond to God
let me respond to God Logic Let Me Wait
hold on one sec because he this is he he
doesn't want to continue to have the
conversation let me just let me just
throw this really quick in there before
you say what you guys because I do agree
that we should do another topic okay
fine so listen
just to just this is the last question
that I'm going to ask on this and you
can you know talk say whatever you want
to say listen
does Allah's knowledge that you would
one day exist mean that you pre-existed
AKA are uncreated yes or no okay I'll
answer your question after I respond
because that kills the whole art your
whole answer I'll answer your question I
have to respond to Avery Avery
you you have lives with Muslims okay and
you pose this question to them okay I
mean a lot of them just say they don't
know this is that in the third none of
them have have proposed what I'm
proposing not to say that I'm coming
with something high and mighty like I'm
on some high horses some some
revolutionary knowledge or something
like that yeah but you're in a position
now where you can change your sense I
mean I see you pundited it over a second
and you asked me a question and as soon
as you're about to switch to your sense
you you stick to your original
bro
I'm not the type to to bend narratives
to to fit what I feel but if new
knowledge comes to me I accept
that's that's one of the qualities of
having a soft heart bro I I propose
something to you yeah and I said
everything in the knowledge of God is
undetermined and then when it's created
it is then determined so our existence
the quran's existence all of it was once
undetermined and then it is determined
because it exists inside the knowledge
of God not in the same way in physical
form now you're about a response and
instead of responding you want to end
the conversation right when you're about
to change your sense this is something
new to propose bro look check it out if
if it's cool it's 100 cool if you just
want to say I don't know or I don't
think about it or something like that
but I wouldn't say throw it away
if wow this is crazy bro
the conversation is circular let's just
move on bro like I get it Haroon
we understand bro but it's it it's not
working bro
the fact that he said that there was a
moment where I was like actually
pondering
like that that shows that you have you
can't read facial expressions yeah you
cannot read it I mean no no you look you
look down and then you ask me a question
I mean he's about to respond to the
question instead of respond to the
question
those were facial expressions of
irritation
not pondering
[Music]